Have you ever heard of Erbil?
Despite threats from Baghdad, it seems probable
that geography students will soon have to
learn the name of this capital city as well
as its new country: Iraqi Kurdistan.
The 25th of September this year was a historical
moment for the more than 5 million Kurds who
currently live in this autonomous community
in the north of Iraq.
And why was this?
Well, that’s because after decades of unfulfilled
promises and ethnic repression, they had the
opportunity to vote in a referendum organized
by the Regional Government of Kurdistan.
Since 2005, and according to the Constitution
of Iraq, Kurdistan is an autonomous region...
but this area worked, essentially, almost
as a totally independent country.
And the result of this was that the population
really wanted to be fully independent.
The day of the referendum, Kurds show up en-mass
at the polling stations.
Even speakers at mosques encouraged voters
to go to the polls.
Well, the final results showed the referendum
was a complete success…
More than 7 out of every 10 Kurds went to
vote.
That almost 3.1 million votes.
The victory was overwhelming for those who
supported independence, obtaining 92.73% of
the vote.
And you know what, this triumph is totally
understandable, because we are talking about
some of the most ill-treated people in history.
And that’s even though the Kurds are, according
to many experts, the most ancient people in
the entire region.
It is estimated that their culture, their
language, theirs rituals, essentially everything
that could define them, have been in this
part of the world (Upper Mesopotamia) for
more than 4,000 years...
In fact, many of these experts consider the
city centre of Erbil, the capital, as the
oldest human settlement to be continuously
inhabited on the planet.
In other words, the Kurds are older than the
Persians or the Arabs.
However, they have suffered from all kinds
of persecution.
See, the total number of Kurds is around 30
million, spread across, mainly, four countries:
Turkey, Iran, Syria and Iraq.
Well, in all these places the Kurds have suffered
the consequences of nationalism that has tried
to make them disappear as a community.
They have tried to end their culture, their
language, as well as trying to close down
their media outlets.
Between 1986 and 1989, Saddam Hussein launched
the “Anfal Campaign” and estimations are
that between 50,000 and 180,000 Kurds died
as a result of this campaign.
And as you might imagine, this cannot be easily
forgotten.
“My grandfather had a good sense of humor.
He used to say he was born a Kurd, in a free
country.
Then the Ottomans arrived and said to my grandfather,
"You're Ottoman," [...] At the fall of the
Ottoman Empire, he became Turkish.
The Turks left and he became a Kurd again.
[...] Then the British arrived, so my grandfather
became a subject of His Gracious Majesty.
The British invented Iraq, so my grandfather
became Iraqi, but [...] to his dying breath
he was never proud of being Iraqi.
Hiner Saleem, “My father's rifle : a childhood
in Kurdistan”.
Considering the history, it is no surprise
that the Kurds want, once and for all, to
make the dream of having their own state come
true.
And if we add up the fact that the Iraqi Kurdistan
is quite a rich area in terms of oil and natural
gas (as well as fresh water, by the way) we
can understand even more why they want independance.
So, to sum up, the Kurds want, and are able,
to build their own country.
And it is beneficial for them, so, well, they
did that.
THE REFERENDUM
As we have said, Kurdistan is almost an independent
country already…
they even have their own army of more than
200,000 soldiers: the Peshmerga, who have
(by the way) been the main defiance to Islamic
State in Iraq.
Do bear this in mind because the government
of Kurdistan is a close ally of Washington.
Maybe their most loyal ally in the area actually.
Because of this, the US has trained, financed
and armed their army.
Some even say that the Kurds are as pro-American
as Texans!
So, after many difficult years of intense
fighting against Islamic State, it has been
clear for the Kurds that there are almost
no advantages in remaining in Iraq.
And the government of Erbil took advantage
of these battles to integrate Kurd areas into
their political space.
For example there is the province of Kirkuk,
who had a majority of Kurds but was not within
the autonomous region of Kurdistan.
Kirkuk is something of a “crown jewel”
and one of the main reasons for conflict with
the Iraqi government, who by the way has not
hesitated to send their troops over to recover
this settlement.
“Iraqi Forces Sweep Into Kirkuk, Checking
Kurdish Independence Drive”
So why is this territory so valuable?
Well, that’s Because Kirkuk is the province
that contains the most oil in Kurdistan...
In fact, it is estimated that around 10% of
all Iraqi oil reserves are concentrated here,
in Kirkuk, and nobody wants to let them go...
In 2007, a referendum should have been conducted
to incorporate (or not) the Autonomous Region
of Kurdistan… but voting never took place.
So when the Peshmerga occupied the city in
order to protect it from Islamic State since
the Iraqi army had literally run away… the
Kurd Government had, de facto, annexed the
territory.
So, with these conditions and with constant
negotiations between Baghdad and Erbil (and
with a growing disconnect between both territories)
they eventually got to the referendum.
“This is the first time in history that
the people of Kurdistan will freely decide
their future.
After that we will start talks with Baghdad,
to reach an agreement over borders, water
and oil”.
Mr Barzani, president of Iraqi Kurdistan.
Now, the government of Iraq opposed this referendum
in every way and the Constitutional Court
of Iraq even outlawed it.
Parliament asked for many things including:
the withdrawal of diplomatic representation
in Erbil, a border closure, and even army
deployment…
In Kirkuk there was also prosecution of the
organizers of the referendum and, of course,
parliament tried their best to remain in control
of all the oil.
But...even with this kind of action by the
Iraqi government, the Kurds didn’t really
care.
And that’s only logical, because despite
the progress of the Iraqi army, the risk
for Kurdistan is probably not in Iraq, but
rather is with the international community.
You see, Turkey and Iran don't even want to
hear about an independent Kurdistan.
That might give the Kurds in their territories
an idea to replicate this success.
Turkey, for instance, has been at war with
the Kurds for decades, but that’s a story
for another day...
The thing is these countries have allied with
Iraq to defy the referendum:
Turkey’s military has confirmed that Turkey
and Iraq will conduct joint military drills
in Turkey, along an area bordering Iraq’s
semi-autonomous Kurdish region.
Iran’s semi-official ISNA news agency reported
that on Sunday that the Supreme National Security
Council closed Iranian airspace to the Iraqi
Kurdish area at the request of the central
government in Baghdad.
And no, it's not just about the possibility
of conflict...
After all, it is likely to be the result of
fear tactics (which are very usual in this
kind of situations) and they rarely work,
by the way.
Remember Kurdistan is a close ally of the
USA and they have an experienced and well
trained army...
No, the bigger issue might be that Kurdistan
needs their neighbours...
This territory is landlocked and they are
very dependent on Turkey: both to export their
oil to and to import anything they might need...
So, a trade blockade would be a serious threat
for this territory.
“The KRG’s economy depends on one pipeline
that sells oil to international markets and
the pipeline goes through Turkey.
You shut down that pipeline, you choke the
Kurdish economy,” Bilal Wahab, analyst at
the Washington Institute for Near East Policy.
But there is more to it than their neighbours.
Nobody wants any more tension with this part
of the world so, .internationally speaking,
the referendum didn´t get much support.
The US has opposed it, and Antonio Guterres,
Secretary General of the UN has described
it as “dangerous and potentially disruptive”.
Today, only Israel clearly supports the independence
of this country.
The future doesn't look very good then, does
it?
Well, wait, because despite all this, it is
likely that Kurdistan will achieve independence
sooner or later...
THE REASONS FOR A NEW COUNTRY
Iraqi Kurdistan has many issues, however they
have managed to become the region that functions
the best in Iraq.
They are the safest and wealthiest area.
“I’ve been to Iraqi Kurdistan a number
of times.
It’s safer than Kansas [...] If you’re
coming from Baghdad or Mosul, it’s practically
Switzerland”.
Michael J. Totten.
American journalist.
Check this out: In 2014, before the IS offensive,
this region was turning into the most relevant
financial and tourist spot in Iraq - an oasis
for many businessmen, both local and foreign...
Skyscrapers, malls, and mansions, were spreading
like mushrooms after the rain…
That was until the war broke out in Iraq against
the Islamic State.
Then, most of this development had to stop.
Now, after some awful years of war, in 2017
the numbers are bouncing back…
And remember that this area is oil rich.
Some estimations calculate the oil reserves
of Kurdistan as 45 billion barrels!
To put it into words, Kurdistan would be among
the 15 oil richest countries on Earth.
And this is in a country with little more
than 5 million inhabitants.
But there is still so much more…
Iraq´s Kurdistan is quite business friendly.
Indeed, they like private initiatives…
something uncommon in this part of the globe.
Taxes are also attractive and bureaucracy
is not excessive either.
Unfortunately though, there is still plenty
of corruption.
“The Kurdistan Government will do its best
to help the private sector and have them invest
here.
[...] I invite all local and foreign investors
here to take advantage of our laws and offers,
and invest”.
Masoud Barzani, president of Iraqi Kurdistan.
The thing is that this region has enough going
for it to make Kurdistan a prosperous country...
They have fertile land, high levels of safety,
and natural resources.
Further, their geographical location is beneficial:
a place between Turkey, Iran and Iraq.
But, on top of that: This new country is only…
well… fair...
The Kurd people, and especially Iraqi Kurds
have been deported, attacked with chemical
weapons, and have suffered all sorts of social
engineering in order to strangle their culture.
And now they have an opportunity to build
their own country.
Further, the rest of us could also benefit
from a more moderate, prosperous and free
country than the ones around it...
The Middle East would certainly be better
for it.
Are what about the problems in today's Iraqi
Kurdistan, are there any?
Well, of course there are, but that is no
excuse to not make this happen.
First, because these problems exist now (with
them still being a part of Iraq), and second:
because they are less serious problems than
the ones in the rest of the country.
So, is there corruption?
Yes, totally.
Is there oil dependency?
Yes indeed.
Debt?
Oh yes, that too...
But this is totally normal in this part of
the world…
The rest of Iraq is in a much worse situation
for sure.
Well, anyway, we just wish that Baghdad's
response does not turn this situation into
a military conflict.
That would be a terrible scenario for everyone,
and would be also one of those situations
where political interests prevailed above
the people’s.
But now it’s time for your opinion: do you
support the independence of Kurdistan?
Well, leave your answer in the comments as
well as in the survey.
Don’t forget to subscribe to our channel
for brand new videos every Monday and Thursday.
Also, don’t forget to check out our friends
at the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine!
And
as always, thanks for watching!